you're at what's your name Jack from
valtech and I'm worth an agency early
you had it Twitter conversation with
someone then very snapchat yeah and and
they said that it was the next myspace
yes and you completely disagree I i also
just posted a medium yeah while I was
gone yeah and i agree content but what
is the next myspace if it's not snapchat
I have no idea and I mean that I really
don't I'm really I don't care to know it
here's why when something fails and dies
i'll leave you read the medium i just
posted something which is everybody so
fixated i'm predicting which app is
gonna win or lose I don't give a [ __ ]
what I care about is marketing while
something is relevant just like the way
people by commercials on television
right when a show is hot you buy ads
when season six comes along and people
stop watching you don't and the fact
that we haven't started using that same
psychology on these emerging platforms
is confusing to me I think because of
the way history happened myspace was so
big it died k facebook i think
everybody's affected by it i think it's
stupid i'm thrilled that people aren't
playing properly more for me and my
clients but you know i don't know what
the next myspace is I know tumblr in my
opinion miss the biggest opportunity if
tumblr went mobile quicker and properly
I'm not sure Instagram would have
happened in the same way I do they're
the ones in the short term that left the
most on the table